[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance in the
kitchen
and this is a show for you if you're
bored which people arguing on the
Internet are the subjects they know
nothing about a trigonometry we don't
pretend to be the experts we ask the
experts
our brilliant guests this week is a
trans youtuber who talks about trans
issues freedom of speech and political
correctness or as a dawn welcome to
trigonometry
Thanks having me on it's great to have
you on the show as you know in recent
weeks we've had an interview of ours
with posy Parker whose agenda critical
ex feminist removed from YouTube for
hate speech it was then reinstated by
the time this video goes out it could
have been deleted again you know the
channel might have been deleted who
knows but if we're still here I know you
watched some of that interview and you
mentioned to us that you thought it was
ridiculous so let's just find anyone who
doesn't know you before we get into that
just tell everybody who are you how are
you where you are how do you happen to
be sitting in this chair here today okay
so as it's blatantly obvious I'm a
transsexual woman I transitioned about
10 years ago now maybe a bit longer
can't quite remember off the top of my
head but throughout my transition I
relied a lot on myself rather than
relying on any kind of community so I
gained a lot of like individual ideas on
what it is to be trans and the kind of
self-reliance that should come along
whether I found the trans community in
not just the UK but just in general as
being one of very weird extremes with a
lot of science denial with a lot of
controlling ideas on what it is to be
trans in a way where it takes away
rights from people like myself now I had
been concerned about this for a long
time but what really made me start my
channel was kind of an argument with a
couple of friends a few years ago where
they talked about how all genders are
valid and I wanted to challenge that and
fought well what about people who
identify his try gender or moon agenda
thinking they would push back at that
and think like no obviously people can't
self-identify as the moon that's
ridiculous
only to learn differently they weren't
offended identifying as the moon it's
like that is just as fathered as being
me and I think really like how do you
transition to be the moon how do you
transition to be free genders at once
and I was just called the transphobia
response and so I started my channel
kind of talking about these kinds of
issues and a lot of it was also
motivated by what happened with can't
danke Ola when he was found guilty of
hate speech because I fought with the
way that a trans community is this is
going to be a real issue as the years go
by with people wanting to control what
others can actually say about the trans
community and as a trans person myself I
found that I've been told to shut up or
even had post removed from social media
because I'm saying that to be trans as
to have gender dysphoria it's - it's not
these like multi gendered hundreds of
genders that the narrative is now being
polished so if I can't talk about this
what about anyone else what about your
average man or woman on the street who
wants to be asked concerns about any of
this
what about the radical feminists so I've
been told for years where my mortal
enemies and wanted me thrown in camps
when I see them trying to hold meetings
on this they get they get shot down some
of them have had bomb threats throned in
activists will turn up in like masks
stopping people from coming in and they
say that they're doing it in the name of
love and doing it in my name as well and
whilst I wanted my channel to initially
be more about politics
more like the center-right or more about
free speech trans issues has become such
a strange hot topic issue that I don't
think I can stay silent on this it's
it's a strange worlds that someone like
myself is actually considered
controversial and the community why do
you think it's become such a strange hot
topic issue because when you think about
it you know trying to fix very a very
very small minority of the population
well that's it it should in theory that
should be right we would be looking at
you know only a couple of fouls and
trans people potentially in the country
if we look at what the original
definition
which is someone who was gender
dysphoria and has made steps to publicly
socially medically transition to be that
which they identify us so for example
myself had to take hormones about
various surgeries about to do various
legal documents everything to show
society that I am very serious about the
way in which I lived this isn't any kind
of fetish this isn't any kind of weird
fantasy of mine this is just who I am
but the current trans Lobby is really
lowering the gate for who can actually
be trans we're now seeing people being
told well you you know you're a male but
you quite like doing this feminine thing
but you're neither male or female then
you must be a special gender of your own
or you will be getting trans women who
are told or people who say that trans
women rather who have no desire to have
any kind of surgeries no medical issue
no taking of medicine at all no changing
their appearance they will grow beards
and they will say well this is a woman's
beard because I am a woman I am a
biological woman I'm not simply not true
like a trans woman by definition cannot
be a biological female otherwise we
wouldn't be transitioning what we and
it's gone from relative obscurity at the
start of the decade to now being
everywhere like a couple of days ago it
was trans Day of Remembrance and there
were trans flags flying everywhere now I
have massive problems of trans Day of
Remembrance but I find that it's become
like this massive focal issue for
everyone when really it should only be
affecting there's very small percentage
of the population and it doesn't seem
right to be able to control what
everyone can do or say when there's so
few people that this actually effects
I'm where the Frances has given you his
customary death stare it's not personal
to you he just puts that face on every
episode of every episode with but it's
called South London face so I'm very
sorry
try and just smile for once in your life
that's not how we communicate myself
because if smiling is weakness but
anyway however what you said transition
to a but you said that you are not a
biological female yes and that is all
that I mean that that's just the
scientific fact but that is seen as
somehow incredibly controversial why I
think with a lot of denialism involved
and and in a way there is some fantastic
fantasy for some of these activists have
when they'll claim well because I say
I'm a woman therefore I am biologically
a woman they will talk about that there
are a variety of different sexes as well
as a variety if they don't it was even
more genders when new genders being
released every week they I say but I
also think there's a bit of control in
this as well the idea that you can have
someone with a full-on beard tell people
that they are a woman you have to accept
them as a woman they have no desire to
get rid of that beard they have no
desire to change their appearance or
anything about them so society could see
them as a woman and it does I know like
mentioning 1984 is such a tight rope at
this point but it is that many what's
two plus two is five like what you're
looking at is a woman even though this
woman there's like a big burly man you
wouldn't know there were a woman unless
you were told by someone that you had to
refer to them as a woman that's not the
way that I think a translation should go
it's as much as I want to be happy with
myself if I want to be treated in a
certain way I have to understand what is
that society expects of me and if
society isn't gonna see me in that way I
cannot command them to do so to do
otherwise as authoritarian and that's
where that's the way a lot of these
activists are going they want to be able
to control what people say and think and
feel about a trans person that's
counterproductive and it makes the whole
situation more hostile it's going to
turn people away from even people like
myself now obviously I think I'm quite
reasonable I don't know about you guys
anyone else but a lot of people do group
of us into various groups and I don't
want to be logged in with these
extremists these people who seem to
completely deny reality and they're
pushing the nora terian and very extreme
agenda so let's explore some of what you
just said that because it makes perfect
sense to me but there are when I think
through the consequences of what you're
saying which is that you say you're not
biologically a woman that's which
biologically as Francis said is correct
right okay but does that not open the
door to people well people will say
you're not a woman young you said you're
a transsexual woman right so does that
mean therefore you're not entitled to
the same things that a natural-born
woman would be are you not opening the
door for discrimination against people
like yourself by talking about it in
that way I think each issue has to be
taken based on what the circumstances
are and might as its own individual
circumstance so for something like
sports for example I'm quite against
trans women being in spot there would be
a different situation if it's someone
who has transitioned very young and has
been taking hormones and stuff and so
they haven't built up the muscle mass
that a lot of testosterone can give you
so for example when you look at a lot of
trans athletes like Rachel McKinnon for
example I think that people like her
should not be competing and women in
sports
it's very notable that these are
athletes who are dominating their you
know whatever field that they're in when
when they were competing in the same
spot when they were males they weren't
actually doing quite as well
you all say it gives the impression of
mild understatement
it gives the impression that they're
doing it for for sports and glory when
it comes to two bathrooms I do think to
simply say that all trans women should
be banned from bathrooms and that it
should only be biological women I don't
think that really address any of the
nuance of what people like myself are
going through I what I think is that is
all individual circumstances and I
understand a lot of what Posey Parker
said or when you get a trans woman who
might go into a bathroom who isn't
very possible I know that a lot of
people find that problematic but [ __ ]
who doesn't look like a woman is
basically anyone who doesn't know what
possible mean yeah I mean my mine line
is always if people put in effort into
that transition at least a little bit of
effort then I will refer to them in that
particular way I do I can understand why
some might well be intimidated by that
but I think a lot of trans women aren't
these poorly dressed like massive blokes
with weird wigs they are some of the
most visible but I think that they are a
minority I would say that a lot of trans
women are more people like maybe it
myself
people like Blaire white people who I've
used women's bathrooms for a very very
long time now I've never had any
problems in it I don't buy this idea
that by me entering a bathroom I'm
intimidating people because I have no
desire to intimidate people I'm
literally going in there just to go to
the bathroom and I think when Posey Park
has said that that some thought like she
was putting a motive on to what our
actions are now where's a
counter-argument and I do a lot of
counter arguments to her so we're just
trying to explore these ideas would be
the intimidation is an eye of the
beholder ok so I personally you look
perfectly possible to me I I wouldn't if
I didn't know you were trans I wouldn't
know you were trans right but there are
people who may not have the same
appearance who may go into a female
bathroom and if you're a woman you may
feel intimidated by that even if the
intention of that person isn't to
intimidate do you know what I'm saying I
can understand that so this is the issue
right because essentially the problem
here is that you have to have someone on
the door of every female bathroom and
the country going you passed you don't
pass you have a penis you don't have a
penis you do you know what I'm saying
and that's simply not gonna happen no
it's why the whole bathroom issue is
almost it's sorry to interrupt there's
some what you're volunteering yourself
[Laughter]
all right you're never gonna be able to
police who can go into a bathroom you're
never going to be able to have like an
ID card
situation because that would be quite
terrifying if you had to Korean ID to
show that you were trans alert you
weren't
trans so in ways it's almost a bit of a
non-issue and I don't mean that as any
disrespect for people who have concerns
but it is something where if you have a
trans woman who passes for example it's
you're not really gonna be able there
isn't a lot that can be done and you can
also get biological women who might fall
foul of this as well I've heard of
examples in the United States where they
both in these bathroom laws but it's
actually it's illegal if you are a male
to use a female bathroom and biological
women have actually been impacted by
that and have been told oh you're a
biological male even though they're not
even though it should be violently
obvious that they're not it can still
happen
it's how does it get resolved well I
don't missus it's this is a fair thing
where I go I probably don't have the
answer to it I can't pretend I have all
the answers to everything I think that
until a lot of the big trunk this trans
conversation came at the forefront of
everything there wasn't much of an issue
on this people would just use the
bathrooms and it would be perfectly fine
but now we're trying to we're making
mountains out of molehills
when we're trying to say well because we
have beardy over here who's now decided
that Z feels more comfortable in a
woman's bathroom so therefore that can
happen Z can go in there it's this we're
getting these weird situations that
which is why people are now asking the
question I mean the self idea is really
the Profi D is the big problem it's it's
something which I think a lot of people
were never really prepared for I mean as
I mentioned earlier trans issues were
never a big thing until just a few eight
years ago and now all of a sudden we've
got the multi gendered nonsense telling
people that you have to accept it like
as an example changing
this is another big one when we have
things like Eman ass thickness and
there's another lingerie store there's
quite a few that just a lot of people to
go and based on how they self-identify
now they didn't have these rules when I
started using them I just used them and
that was fine nobody batted an eyelid
everyone was cool with it but a lot of
this has kind of come about since we've
had a lot of non-binary people try and
pull this off like this non-binary
activist called Travis alabanza who made
headlines a few years ago after they
decided that they wanted to use the
women's changing room in a Topshop
Travis doesn't look like a woman Travis
doesn't even claim to be a woman but
says that they are non-binary and they
just so happened to feel more
comfortable in the women's so Travis
went into the women's changing room stop
shops policy the dead allow them to do
that and so even though they got in
trouble with some of the stuff we were
like no you clearly a bloke like get out
of here right now if Travis got a
massive apology from them and what is
non-binary I'd still can't understand
what is it so not buying there E is
something which is quite difficult to
describe because a lot of people have
their own weird definitions of it
effectively what it means is you don't
identify as male or female and the
barrier for entry is basically
non-existent this is where the likes of
the attack helicopter meme or Piers
Morgan claiming to be a penguin came
about because there is a list of various
different genders that you can identify
us and be non-binary this can range from
being a demi boy or genderqueer or
gender fluid to genders that sounds
incredibly strange when you look at the
definition I can't quite remember the
name of it but there is a gender which
is a hundred percent of one gender and
then also a bit of and other gender is
really
there's another one which is like your
gender is like water your gender is like
space your genders like fire your own
you can only have this particular gender
if you are autistic like you so these
are like people making up their own ways
of describing themselves and it feels
very much like a fad um this goes along
with a lot of the pronouns that these
people use I remember being at a party a
couple of years ago when someone
announced that they had new pronouns and
a lot of people applauded them and they
felt like a way of getting attention
nowadays people are a lot less
suppressed than they ever have been even
if you're like quite a hard-line
intersectional activist you can't
seriously compare times now that they
were 50 years ago and so it's a lot
harder to claim that you are a victim
however if you're non-binary and nobody
understands you it's a very easy way to
earn some impression points and we see a
lot of middle-class women doing this
Lorri penny for example claims that she
is non-binary and she comes from a very
well-off backgrounds you know she's
educated a prestigious university she
goes all around the world writing and so
just saying that she's a woman isn't
enough oppression anymore but she can
claim to be non-binary and now you know
she is more of a victim she got to
listen to her more and a lot of it seems
like a power play and to simply identify
now as trans that gives you that
oppression status you'll no more oppress
than other groups you they forget the
talking stick so you can control the
conversation and people always talk
about the oppression that trans people
face there you know the fact that you
know there are members of the public who
are actively hateful and I I wouldn't
pretend to know what it's like to be a
trans person do you find that people are
intolerant on a day to day basis
everything okay I've actually found the
vast vast vast vast majority of people
to not care and that's exactly what I
want I want to be able to just go
outside and do whatever it is I need to
do in the day and I don't get treated
any differently to anyone else and
that's the experience that I've had
even at the earliest times of my
transition I'm not saying that I've
never had any genre I've had a couple of
people for abuse at me in the past like
that absolutely happened but the
overwhelming majority of my experience
has been positive that people generally
are quite decent and they don't want to
hurl abuse but they're not hateful deep
down they don't care that and so when I
hear about how we've got record levels
of transphobia record levels of abuse I
don't see it I don't see it with some of
my friends either because I do have
other trans friends obviously and they
don't suffer this either so I've got to
ask the question where is this we're
hearing about more and more transphobia
but where is this coming from like who
were the victims in this that's kind of
like immigrants as well that there's a
lot of evidence that people if you
measure reported hate crimes yeah on the
rise but if you ask the public if you
take a random sample of the public and
you sample them hate crimes have never
been lower than they are right now so
more people are reporting them but if
you ask an ordinary person have you been
a victim of a hate crime the statistics
are dropping rapidly so it's this
imbalance between people reporting more
and actually the level of offense
dropping rapidly of course that goes
back to the Posie Parker who knows then
you know reported to the police based on
a hate crime of simply having a
disagreement with people online well
let's talk about this because as you
know we had her on the show the the
video was taken down because it was hate
speech which quote caused or incited
hatred or violence what do you make of
that having seen that video well I don't
think that posy was inciting violence at
all machine side and hatred I don't
think so I think I think in fighting
hatred is something which is very hard
to define I do think that there is
intolerance
of trans people certainly but I don't
think that in itself should be a crime
and I think that people should be
allowed to listen to him whether I agree
with what she says or not and there are
things in particular with her language
that I did disagree with I went
she would use terms talking about like
this idea that we were walking to
intimidate that we're lying to be
pretending pretending like I can
disagree with that language but she
gains my sympathy once she starts to be
silenced for it like she isn't calling
for violence she isn't using terms that
are like outright slurs as it were it's
just more of a walk around use of
language and it we're walking on very
tricky grounds if we're going to stop
someone from talk and and I have to
start policing language they use and now
she was calling they transmit electronic
that then that might be a bit of a
different situation but she wasn't then
she should be free to express their
opinions on this just as I should be
free to disagree with her one of the key
issues that sorry first cuz I was going
to say now we were talking about hate
speech and incitement to violence or a
number of trans activists who would say
that misgendering somebody is hate
speech and incitement to violence and is
itself an act of violence I mean I I've
seen I've seen it as well when people
will suggest that yeah it's who
misgender someone is underneat and
active violence of course it's not it's
not violence you can say it's rude you
can say it's disrespectful and again
that goes into like the kind of person
that we're talking about like I would
certainly say it's disrespectful to
refer to someone like Blair white as a
man but it would be is it as
disrespectful to refer to someone who
again I know I keep on mentioning the
beard reference but I've come across a
lot of so-called trans women who have
beards is it disrespectful to them it's
society wise probably not and are you
really talking about passing there
aren't you again yes I am but it's not
even if you were to Miss Jones on myself
for Blair white it's not hate speech
it's not violence against us it's just
rude and like surely people have the
freedom to be rude like I can take my if
someone's going to misgender me I can
just walk away from calm
sation I can choose to remove myself
from that and I don't have to deal with
that person but that's very different
from calling the Staton to try and
violence them and so I don't want to
talk to this person therefore nobody
else can because one day that will that
power could be used against me and it
probably was in that kind of situation
because a lot of these people I do have
agreement with and I but it's not
violence
it's misgendering isn't violence using
the wrong pronouns isn't violence and
especially when we have been on binary
elements in sweat when we have people
saying that they want to identify as
whatever and use these magical pronouns
that you've never really heard before
I've never been a part of our that of
any kind of dialogue but they're not
being forced on you and you're expected
to use those pronouns and if you don't
you're committing a hate crime that's
that's kind of what they're pushing for
when they when they try and compare
using wrong pronouns using misgendering
as an act of violence
I really hope YouTube take down this
video that we're doing we can accuse
them of transphobia it's interesting
what you're saying do you think that
this actually damages the trans cause
yeah absolutely
it paints the image that we are
irrational that we are incredibly
aggressive that we don't have any kind
of critical thinking on to who we are
and that one most important that we are
perpetual victims like when I started my
transition years ago it didn't go off to
the easiest start I lost a lot of
friends I had some difficulties with my
family but was able to persevere and get
over it
as a result I've now made an incredible
life for myself I have a fantastic group
of friends my relationship with my
parents has never been stronger I have a
good job I've been able to take myself
out and do very interesting things
throughout the world and I started my
youtube channel which has really taken
off I'm in no way a victim and I hate
the assertion that trans people are
being victims and that's one of the
narratives that this is pushing that we
are these weak pathetic individuals that
have to have all those nanny anse and
you have to respect those and if you
don't
then you know you could cause our
suicides and you could also then be
thrown in jail you could be removed from
social media you could lose your job and
then when you got your typical layman on
the street why would they want to
interact with us if their impression of
us is that we are so weak that we have
to call the police every time where our
feelings are hurt like it's it makes us
look pathetic it makes us look or ferret
Aryan and I'm an individualist I don't
like groupthink ideologies why I'm very
much against the likes of fascism and
communism communism in particular is
bizarrely prevalent within the trans
community but it is since we're defining
things one of the issues where I
disagree that was proposed he said the
most was probably around gender
dysphoria because I don't remember the
exact words that she used but
essentially I think she was quite
unwilling to acknowledge that it happens
yeah like what is gender dysphoria now
so gender dysphoria is something which
is admittedly quite hard to explain and
understand it is effectively a
discomfort between your real biological
sex and the way in which your mind feels
as though it should have been wired now
there is currently no real answers to
what causes gender dysphoria there are
various different theories from the way
in which your brain is wired to social
raising but I would say certainly the
latter that doesn't ring true to me but
effectively if that is what is a
transsexual person that they have gender
dysphoria and so you transition as a way
of treating it and it's recognized as a
medical condition it is however there
are trans activists who are trying to
get that removed and that is a
terrifying prospect for me I relied on
medical treatment and particularly the
NHS as for a lot of my transition apart
from my face of a gentle reassignment
surgery about my hormones I've had
various different therapies or related
to it and that so it's the medical
aspect it's certainly real this is
another point where I
conflict a lot with trans activists
because they think that anyone can just
choose to be trans whereas my argument
is and always I really has been that we
are we can't really control who we are
but we have this condition we treat it
by transitioning and yeah we put a
border on the walls a border on gender
but they want to open it and simply
declare that anyone can identify is
whatever they want and therefore they
are the same as me I had to go through a
lot to get all that free work to where I
am and I think really actually be
respected I think India willaby actually
said the same thing when she's on the
show she said the demon Dee
medicalization of trans is a problem let
me ask you this and it's quite an
unpleasant question for me to ask but
people do say this so I just want to get
your take on it what about the argument
that people sometimes feel like they
they're in the wrong body they've got
too many hands right they've got two
hands that they should really have only
one hand people say this right I'm not
saying this from my perspective I'm just
putting the counter-argument that some
people say that being trans is like a
medical condition yeah there is in your
head but if someone came in and said
well I've got too many hands doctor
please chop off one hand and one foot
and one year we wouldn't go with that
right well not really no I think that's
this seems to be somewhat why are they
doing what is the motivation behind
someone one thing to just say well I
identify as a one handed person rather
than like what when I do a transition I
don't know what I'm not really doing any
kind of harm to myself by doing it
whereas a self-mutilation is actually
stopping you from being able to perform
certain tasks like for example if you
lose your and you can't really do
anything right there you know what I
mean I mean Road we do always hear this
argument of like well we can certify
that when people pull up these they know
trans abled people who self-identify as
being disabled and we may actually take
steps to to [ __ ] themselves and to
to follow that now I've no it's not
subject I've really looked into all I
can comment on is what the science is on
being transsexual person yeah which I
know that there was there is no
conclusive answer there is certainly
something that and it's certainly enough
to be recognized but I would say that if
you are get it the other thing is is not
really changing the way in which people
have to perceive you if that makes sense
yeah your hand is not demanding to be
recognized as a new that was a different
whatever yeah anyway I would say that
they are I wouldn't really see a lot of
correlation there like I've only really
considered the actual proper way which
I've had to go through I would say just
simply comparing me to someone who has
chopped off their hands is bit
disrespectful yeah and where do you
stand on another argument Posey had
which was the thin end of the wage we're
saying well you know if you know
somebody has to acknowledge that you are
a woman and that they have to
acknowledge and use certain pronouns
eventually it means a sliding scale and
then we get trans women in Olympic
sports and you know obliteration of
women's spaces etc etc well it's a
slippery slope fallacy basically and not
everything if that's taken very
black-and-white view of the world
I can under certain Leon Durst and
concerns around that for example as we
mentioned earlier about trans athletes
and I think that there are some issues
where trans people might actually have
to kind of take a step back but it
should never be an all-or-nothing
situation it should never be a case of
either you know we can compete in the
Olympics or we can't even you bathrooms
like that's an easy no it's that's quite
an extreme response whatever way you are
on that scale I think that there are
some instances where trans women can't
back off example being like rape crisis
centers there's one in Vancouver which
had its funding polls because a trans
woman basically contested the fact that
they didn't allow trans women in there
and this is a sensor which had a lot of
vulnerable women in a
you know people who have gone through a
lot of abuse from by males and I've seen
that these photos of this trans woman so
to speak who they're very very low
effort and like no efforts at all
basically like a guy but was allowed
into a rape crisis center taken photos
naked and bathroom so this kind of thing
does happen and I think around very
vulnerable people that might have to be
a little bit more of a barrier there but
I would say that a bathroom or changing
room is very different to like a space
for vulnerable or truly vulnerable
people okay it's a sensible you know
it's a sensible point you're making that
we need to take every you know situation
and judge it on its own merit it has to
be taken like that you can't simply push
that all trans women are automatically
women and we're there for biological
women because we simply identify as such
like there's that the whole debate
requires so much nuance my main concern
with one of my biggest concerns or is
the way to debate is going as nuanced as
going through the window it's either
trans women or biological women and
therefore look at Big Bertha over there
were pregnant at least that's a
biological woman there or it's the case
of like now these are all like mutilated
freaks who have huge problems and it's
cruel to even refer to them as a woman
so I've seen that argument be used by
gender critical feminists at times that
referring to me with female pronouns or
anything like that is an act of Cruelty
and it's simply an act of violence on
them if I was to even ask that not
demands that they do it but simply ask
them to do so is considered violence to
them so there are two very strange
extremes in this debate and you know we
always talk about you know the LGBTQ Y
and all the rest of it and we we see you
know from the outside it's seen as this
big homogeneous group everybody walks
around with rainbow flags everybody's
happy and loving all the rest of it what
I didn't realize is that there's that
there's an enormous tension between the
trans community and the lesbian
community yeah could you just over a
little bit into that and then why there
is such tension between the two so the
one of the reasons for the
is with the main prominence of trans
people in these spaces over the last
couple of years and especially at the
Montreux trans women are biological
women because that's what they mean when
they say trans women are women not just
that we are socially considered women
but we are biological women there's the
notion that turning down a trans woman
for latent sexual purposes or whatever
is a transphobic action now this is
something which does happen when you
have a trunk like where you're how like
a trans woman asking or lesbian out and
lesbian says no and trans women are here
at [ __ ] transferred in fact this
happened to a friend of mine she met a
trans woman wasn't actually aware that
she was trans and so they properly like
mat up you know as she had a penis said
I'm not interested in that she was
considered transphobic for doing so and
she's someone who isn't very much
involved in this very woke like queer
lefty space hmm and you know she was
considered Ruxin so there's a seat for
saying that so you get this like
confliction where lesbians and gay men
as well are being told that they have to
accept trans people as potential
partners and to not do so is considered
an acts of hate that can be a very
intimidating thing when you've been very
much involved in this queer community
for years and people in the queer
community rarely venture out of it and
so you're now being told by the way you
now have to be open to sleeping with
these people if you don't then you're on
your own in that hateful Tory Trump
filled world and so they don't know what
to do and when they do speak out against
it they are considered that you know
they'll be called tear they'll be caught
you know I have all sorts of a beast
thrown at them now some of these people
are genuinely transphobic I've come
across quite a few who are but a lot of
them aren't a lot of them just have
concerns and they're still branded as
figures of hate even when what they're
saying is just look I'm just attracted
to of a winning biological women what
was wrong with that like you know gone
for years are fighting for like gay
equality and the idea that no it's
perfectly fine for a month
a man or a woman sleep with number one
and now all of a sudden that's been
being told that you're being transphobic
for doing that
like that's awfully bizarre but it's the
same way when you see like because I've
seen a couple of straight people be
accused of being transphobic for not
sleeping with trans people so it doesn't
just impact the the lesbians are the
gays it also impacts everyone it's kind
of straightforward though I mean if
you're a lesbian you're not you're by
definition not attracted to people with
penises yeah and if if you're a straight
man again you're not attracted to people
I mean I saw that they're basically
saying that you're a bigger for having
any sexual preferences in fact Rachel
McKennon who I mentioned earlier trans
huge and successful cyclist issue that's
incredible also good guilty criticizing
Rachel McKinnon because the Russians
have been doing this she did we had Fred
a couple of months ago where she
actually said that sexual preferences
are immoral and that you should be open
to having fun with anyone of any gender
or sex or whatever and so the only
acceptable sexuality is planned
sexuality which is like bisexuality but
you would also sleep with people who
identify his chairs if you're straight
you're now right-wing one of the things
I talked to I know you you were into it
by Karl sargon of akkad recently and I
talked to him about this I mean one of
the things that seems to me to be
happening is and him and I talked about
this if you were to poll the general
public on this issue and you were to say
is someone who has transitioned from
being male to being female a biological
woman hmm I think you know I'm pretty
comfortable that it would be in the high
90s of people who would say no to that
well of course because you've told them
this person is biologically male and
they've now transitioned to be a woman
right like you don't change biology when
you transition do everything you can to
fit that biology and make yourself as
comfortable as you can't be but
transition is never 100% perfect and yet
if I were to go on national television
or radio or eiope
newspaper saying a person who's
transitioned is not biologically the sex
which they claim to now be or the gender
which they claim to now be you you would
you would be destroyed
mmm overnight yeah so essentially we now
live in a situation where the opinion of
a tiny minority of people is the one
that is allowed to be heard and to be
spoken and the opinion of the
overwhelming majority of the public is
the one that is not allowed to be spoken
and not allowed to be heard yeah is that
accurate I would say so yeah like it's
controversial I've even seen trans women
be banned from Twitter simply for saying
that their biological males they're not
calling over people biological males are
simply saying look I'm a trans woman
okay I see myself as a woman but I am
biologically male so really that pretty
much said that exact message and she got
banned for it III known countless trans
women who that has happened to so Eva's
and really can't say it even we're not
allowed to say it
and what do you think of the long term
implications of that I think it gives a
very misleading idea of what we are I
think it makes a locker so we are a lot
more like unhinged we really deny the
reality that it also sidelines
biological women and biological men as
well because it says that a man's issue
is no longer about like testicular
cancer or women's issue is no longer
about pregnancy and you see this when
you have these more intersectional more
progressive women's rights groups in
particular where they'll be considered
talking about periods as but it's
problematic if it's what if you got
trans women in the room because not all
women have periods not all women can get
pregnant it's the same that you see it
with men's groups as well well not all
men have you know like you know some men
have periods some man can give birth and
there was a we remember the name of the
group there was a group a couple of days
ago that was saying like yes men can get
pregnant they cou yes that's the great
thing about that as you know if men
could get pregnant they'd do it better
we smash agenda would be 18% better and
being pregnant yeah
well it's it's just it's clown well
doesn't it yeah he's absolute clown
world mmm it's and it's become not for
everyone and it's why I find it such a
strange issue that is now at the
forefront of everything we talk about
it's a small group of extremists who
have successfully infiltrated and
effectively kicked me out of what should
be my own community and they're now
effectively taking on the world and
everyone's bending the knee to them they
acting as though there's some sort of
weird authority to these like they can't
they they when even when you look at a
lot of the issues that they campaigned
on in the name of trans rights a lot of
them have nothing to do with being trans
like as an example the any worse
national unity is their transcript has
frightened for such trans issues as
prison abolition like which is
convenient for their former trans
officer who was suspended a mixed
serious allegations of gross sexual
misconduct but with you but within the
deck out at work because the NUS has put
there's a serious point the NUS are
purposely burying it so you have a
someone who's been accused of sexual
abuse way up in the NUS and the NUS is
completely shutting down any discussion
of it and and they have act they had
access to vulnerable people yet has
there been a court case about it I'm
aware that there is a police matter
however the anyway that this has been
going on for way more than a year at
this point and the Nu answers simply as
far as I'm aware this person still being
paid by the NUS Wow yep Jess Bradley
look look after someone is trying to
make they campaign that a lot of these
are hardline communists they're ones who
put in Marxist ideology into their into
their conferences but they do it in the
name of people like me and then they say
well if you're right how can you be
right-wing and beat
how can you vote Tory and be trans and
like well because I'm an individual I
have my own political beliefs like I
consider myself a classic liberal I am
not in any way a collectivist but with
the way that identity politics is you
have so many people who kidnap it for
their own political gains and we're
seeing that more obviously than any
other group and with the trans group
like we have there are and there are
actual like ante for activists within a
lot of trans organizations and
everyone's perfectly fine with that well
Francis is a very tolerant and open
accepting person but when you said your
vote and Tory it does seem like you use
a phrase clown world it just seems that
we're just descending into lunacy and so
you look at you know what's happening
with you know the og DPG btq do you
think part of this is the fact that
we've made such huge strides in equality
we've made such huge strides in
tournament you know we're you know of
course they still homophobia of course
there is but compared to even 30 years
ago you know we live in so much more of
a fairer society that really we don't
have as much to rail against as before
so we need to find smaller and smaller
things to get upset about yeah
absolutely we progressed so much even in
my own lifetime I mean help when I first
transitions out ten years ago it was a
completely different landscape so what
it is now now there is those actual
acceptance a lot of people will accept
me for who I am they will treat me just
as they would treat anyone else things
have never been better
but you're right we have to always find
other ways of making ourselves victims
there has to be something we can rail
against especially with all of these
like gonna fight ill interest groups
within like the oppression Olympics they
have to be oppressed by something
otherwise they're completely obsolete so
this is how you find problems like same
man spray
for example like that's not really a
problem that's not really comparable to
we're taking as little space as possible
to give you as a woman opportunity to
speak your mind they feel comfortable in
the space therefore crushing our own
genital yes yeah that's the level of
progressivism you see on this yeah but
yeah we've we've moved on a lot so so
much that we're picking and choosing
like all the tiniest little issues and
like again the trans movement isn't the
only one that's doing it you named an
intersectional movement they're doing it
as well but I notice at the most with
the transform where it is all of these
weird there she's like leave people on
demanding trans rights and I was at a
trans pride march that a couple of
months ago filming for me my youtube
channel and one of the guys on a
microphone remember him shouting like
when I say we have you say trans rights
and then he realized straight away what
he said and he's like no no no no no we
don't have right what rights do we not
have what what am i I'm not allowed to
do that anybody else will be allowed to
do like I cannot think
oh and the only things that could well
be is that only you're not allowed to
compete in the Olympics like well got no
desire to compete in the Olympics
I've got no desire to join like a
women's board or anything so what else
is there really to accomplish so they
have to find all of these pointless
arguments and fights and the actors
though we're in the dark ages almost and
it's never been worse I know I know you
say that you personally don't want to
compete in the Olympics but I think
that's where a lot of the complications
come in because there are people who
want to sell on a board there are people
who want to be in an always women's
short list there are and and this is
where it's a very as you said it's a
very complicated very nuanced issue and
unfortunately we've run out of time
don't have the time to explore oh
perhaps another time we can yeah get you
guys on the show and talk more about it
but for now our final question is always
the same question
it's what's the one thing that we're not
talking about it's a society that we
really need to be talking about
we really need to be talking well it has
to be related to try okay so one thing
we're really not talking about an office
the rise of the far left and within
society in general what we're seeing in
particular with the Labour Party at the
moment is when we got members former
members of the Communist Party being
engaged in it that they are becoming a
lot more authoritarian and nobody is
questioning this we're too fixated on
the far-right which is of course a
concern but the current way in which our
society is going is almost down a dark
path mean we're pretty close I don't
know whether this is going to come up
before the election or afterwards but
you know we're quite close to a point
where Jeremy Corbyn could be in power by
the time this comes out I don't know a
lot of concern for things like freedom
of speech as well
I mean freedom of speech is certainly
something we're not addressing enough
but right now I think the far left us is
something which is on the rise like
absolutely be concerned about the far
right but look at everywhere that
socialism has ever been tried like
everywhere it's been a cratis trophic
raelia except Venezuela there is no real
socialism unless it's successful which
is never done anyway don't thank you so
much for coming on we will put a link to
YouTube channel in the description of
video thanks for watching we'll see you
again in a week with another brilliant
episode take care see you next week
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word
you